shorts rang out at the beginning of the
weekend in one of the busiest areas of
Tel Aviv police say the shooter was shot
dead the area has been cleared and
police and Medics are on the scene
while handling the protests a terrorist
arrived at Disney golf 171 fired at
three people wounded them and fled we
have carried out all possible tests and
we are still scanning to locate more
terrorists as of now all the protests
have dispersed
the prime minister is on an official
visit to Italy where he reacted to the
news we send first of all our hopes and
our
wishes for the
speedy recovery of the woman and we
strengthened the security forces and the
police
Tel Aviv has been witnessing
anti-government protests and the area
where the shooting took place was busier
than normal the mayor of Tel Aviv has
asked to protesters to return home the
shooter is a Palestinian man from nalin
in the occupied West Bank police and
security forces are investigating the
motives of the attack the last shooting
in Tel Aviv was in April last year when
a Palestinian man killed three Israelis
a massive claimed responsibility for the
attack and the spokesman of the mass in
Gaza has reacted saying that the heroic
operation in Tel Aviv is a natural
reaction to the crimes of the occupation
and its security measures are collapsing
the spokesperson of Islamic Jihad is
also reacted saying the operation in Tel
Aviv destroyed the Zionist security
system and dealt a severe blow to it now
there are fears of escalation some 77
Palestinians have been killed since the
beginning of the year it's likely that
this attack will spark more Israeli
raids and those are occurring on a near
nightly basis in the occupied West Bank
Imran Khan Al Jazeera occupied East
Jerusalem